It's just an image of fast-forwarding the scenery with a fixed-point camera, is
n't it? When I see that, I'm really impatient.
I can say that I can be struck, or I can take it as a dislike for what I was able to
do with Olga, but I think I didn't have time yet.  If you
walk a little on the west coast while eating a little sherry and fudge brownie,
the quality of the darkness is the United States
. Why shouldn't you get
along with me?
I mean, you're okay with your throat, because I was irritated even if I looked like this
tan
[Music] I was
surprised that an Indian movie started
.  But gradually, it's a manager, but it's decided how beautifully it's decided
to buy it.
Even the manager is a kick to the jaw, but that's not the case
.  I was on a gastritis diet,
but it's not suitable for actual battles, but it's a scale that you can put on. You're said to be a taxi driver with a brownie, and you're not annoyed
.  By the way, I
didn't understand what the sticky blade was, and I was angry.
I can understand it from the nuances, but
it's easy to convey the mat.
Yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can call it 9 wins that can be called the old 4 towns